each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so it's a great pleasure to introduce
emery Berger an associate professor at
the University of Massachusetts in
Amherst and we got his PhD in 2002 from
the University of Texas and I've been
working with him since then on a number
of different projects I have to say
Emory always surprises me by the
creativity of his work and also by the
fact that he takes ideas that you think
are just out of this world and he makes
them work in practice so so I think this
is another example of that work and
today I'm reason to talk about parallel
programming in grace thanks Ben hi
everybody all right so uh you see the
title of talk grace safe multi-threaded
programming for c and c++ but what i
want to talk about first is garbage
collection this may seem a little
surprising but you know garbage
collection is a topic that obviously
welted i'm not sure if it's near and
dear to my heart but at least it was at
one time but it's it's a
well-established technology it's
something that that it now works right
so here's there's a the world's best
garbage collector wall-e he never stops
there's always garbage to be found and
you know the idea of garbage collection
at least the idea for wall-e is you've
got a robot and the robot is going to
find your garbage and take care of it
and in a garbage collected language
right the runtime takes care of your
memory ours and this is great you can
deposit your garbage wherever you feel
and the runtime will go after it and
clean it up so this is actually Hans
Bohm by the way for you don't recognize
him I mean Hans is hi this is especially
suitable here so Hans built this
conservative garbage collector foresee
that you all may have heard of and
really it's exactly what I'm getting at
which is it's garbage collection that is
intended to deal with programmer errors
so you're in the world of see you make
some mistake in your memory management
you throw Hans at the problem and the
problem goes away all right Hansie right
so you know the result of all of this
this work on garbage collection
it's a success story right there are now
plenty of languages where a garbage
collection is now practically taken for
granted
and you know for many many years it was
considered very controversial
who would ever adopt it and now you know
you can barely think of I think there
are no dynamic scripting languages for
example they don't have garbage
collection JavaScript of course Python
Perl Ruby
not to mention Java and c-sharp it only
took 35 years so you know I guess you
know if your patients like wall-e that
all good things come to those who wait
okay so wouldn't it be nice if someday
we could have garbage collection for
concurrency so this is sort of the the
vision of this talk I would like to be
in a world where I can take my program
that has all kinds of bugs right I just
throw you know I write a concurrent
program with just as many bugs as I want
I leave off locks
it's full of races and then wall-e comes
and will clean up after me I think that
would be great so I just want you to you
know think of the rest of this talk
through this this sort of view of
garbage collection for concurrency all
right okay the one question immediately
comes to mind though is wait a second
what does that even mean what would it
mean to garbage collect concurrency
errors we know what it means to garbage
collect memory errors concurrency it's
not so clear okay so a lot of this is is
not going to be new but we'll go through
it anyway you know in the beginning
there was the core the core was good and
every year the core got faster and
faster and life was wonderful and so if
you wanted to write a sequential program
right you just write your sequential
program every year it got faster and
faster you just write a very simple
program you're not meant to understand
this but it's just a very very simple
loop and it was great until one day
things got a little too hot and now
we're out of luck right it leveled off
and so then they said oh wait wait you
know we know how to build the one core
what if we give you four and we said we
don't want four they said sorry you're
getting four so now we have
for course and the promise of course is
well if you give me more cores then I
can run faster because I can do more
things at once right the last little
stripe that has to lag along um does law
alright so that's great and if we could
do this if we could paralyze all our
programs right it would be as if Moore's
law never stopped now I'm being a little
loose and fast with what Moore's law
means but you all get the idea okay the
problem of course is anybody in this
room knows who has programmed concurrent
programs how many of you have written
concurrent programs okay how many of you
of you have written concurrent programs
that have bugs okay all right Don is
like what bug me so here's the kind of
problem you get right you run the
program once it works fine you run it
again something else happens sometimes
it works sometimes it doesn't right so
these are races of course and if you
look at this code you can see that
there's indeed a race if you imagine
this being multi-threaded down in this
loop down here if this was a parallel
for the problem is that these are races
right color and row and draw box are
being done really need locks around them
so you then throw box around the updates
to color and row you would think
everything would work and it will
prevent races but unfortunately
sometimes you get this or this which is
rather surprising and so these are
atomicity violations so here the problem
is you put locks around things but you
made them too fine-grained you really
wanted to draw this whole rectangle in a
color and then do the next one the next
one I not change the color while you're
drawing the row so you need to move the
lock up and you know for those of you
who like transactional memory you know
pretend that lock and unlock means you
know atomic and curly braces all right
same thing and and I should observe in
passing
you know it's transactional memory does
not solve any of these problems right
it's really a question of where you put
these braces so if you make a mistake
and you would put them where they were
here you would have exactly the same
problem you need to put the braces in
the right place and transactional memory
does not deal with this
right you still relies on the programmer
to get it right okay
so here's another kind of problem so the
one thing transactional memory does deal
with which is deadlock unfortunately
sometimes it converts it to live lock
which is far far worse but we won't get
into that
okay so here's another weird error if
you see this there's the flag one flag
too so this is what's called an order
violation this was as a recently
identified concurrency error which i
think is great
uh you know good new errors fabulous so
so the new error is programmers wrote
this code assumed that when you spawned
a thread that that thread would be
delayed it wouldn't just spawn
immediately and so they then did some
other stuff right after they spawned the
thread and almost all the time that
other stuff preceded the actual
execution of the next thread but then
they changed versions of the OS so the
scheduler changed all of a sudden the
threads started executing first and
weird things happen so fun concurrency
errors
so to recap back in the day when we had
the one core it was great everything was
sequential no bugs right remember all
right
it was maybe easier okay and you know it
was a world of unicorns and rainbows
cooperatively so now we have races
atomicity violations deadlock order
violations so so this is concurrency
hell so it's a bad situation so what
we'd like to be able to do is to come up
with the world that takes us back to
those unicorns and rainbows to some
extent and so the object of grace which
is what I'm going to talk about today
which is you can view as a sort of
garbage collector for concurrency it's
intended to get rid of all of these
errors okay and impose sequential
semantics so you'll take your
multi-threaded program and it will run
as if you had written a sequential
program okay so I'll explain what that
all means in some detail the idea behind
grace however it's not a new compiler
it's a runtime solution roughly speaking
to use gray
you swap out the pthreads library for
the grace library and you don't need to
make any other changes to your code okay
this guarantees sequential semantics
gets rid of these errors and I'll show
you how you can actually get some
performance out yes yeah well that's
exactly the next thing right so in the
rest of the talk the very first thing
I'm going to talk about is going to
address that question which is what the
hell do I mean right I've got
multi-threaded programs that are gonna
run on multiple cores and now I'm saying
they're sequential what do I mean by
that I'll talk a little bit about what
goes on inside right what's under the
hood and then presents some results okay
all right so to the first question so
for the purposes of this talk I'm gonna
use the syntax of the silk programming
language for those of you who are
unfamiliar this is a c-like programming
language this is extended with spawn
which is the moral equivalent of pthread
create and sync which is the moral
equivalent of pthread join for all of
the preceding children syntactically
it's just cleaner and makes the examples
easier but grace actually implements the
pthreads api okay so here is a little
program that says spawn a thread to run
the function f of X and store the result
in t1 same thing with G of Y and t2 and
sink means wait for both of those
threads to complete okay very simple
multi-threaded program so the execution
looks something like this you say spawn
f of X f of X starts executing it runs
concurrently with the main program which
now spawns G now everything is running
concurrently until they hit sink and
sink is like a barrier okay all right so
that's your concurrent program so what I
want to do is I want to take this
concurrent program and I want to impose
an order on the execution what I'm going
to to impose in particular is a left to
first depth-first ordering left to right
I mean depth-first ordering but what
that corresponds to is actually much
easier to explain syntactically all we
do is we get rid of the keywords spawn
and Silke so this is sort of an elysian
of all of the concurrency operatives
in the code and you're left with a
sequential program so where you had a
function call before that was supposed
to be throat spawned asynchronously in
another thread now it's going to be
executed synchronously so f of X will be
executed to completion then G of Y so
these are the semantics that grace is
going to provide okay it's not really
going to execute them this way because
that would defeat the whole purpose of
having multiple threads from multiple
cores okay yes exactly so so first let
me say what this does what the
implications are and then I'll talk
about the limitations and you're
absolutely right so first it should be
clear that most of these problems go
away right as soon as you moved into a
sequential world these sort of
concurrency errors by definition stop
really mattering so a race doesn't
matter if threads aren't running in
concurrency same thing with that
immensity violations
we don't need locks anymore because
there aren't multiple threads so that
gets rid of deadlock and there's no
order violations the order is fixed its
program order okay
however there are some limitations if
you have threads that are intended to
execute forever so some sort of a
reactive thread so if f of X and G of Y
when you spawn them they were both
supposed to run forever
now we compose them and F runs forever
and G never runs you have a bit of a
problem so you can't have infinite
thread execution the other thing which
is perhaps a more crucial limitation is
they can't communicate either okay they
can communicate in the sense that the
effects of one thread become visible to
the next thread or to a child thread but
they can't use condition variables so in
fact in grace condition variables are
not exposed in the library if you try to
link with the grace library and you have
condition variable calls it will
complain a compile time all right so
this sort of communication is ruled out
okay
you can't delay Rome at my home channels
I mean there's yeah you can't implement
I mean any sort of thing that does that
you know there's no way to actually
implement it in grace right you're
prevented from doing so and the
primitives aren't exposed okay oh well I
mean okay I see so you want to you want
to violate the boundaries right yeah
okay sure yes that's right there there
are certain certain evil things you
could do to try to get past this and
then you know if you if you roll your
own or you include something that's not
called pthread cond whatever it's called
you know Manuel cond then grace doesn't
know about it and it will not behave as
you would like okay what it's intended
for is for fork/join parallel code so
the whole object of writing these
parallel programs ostensibly is to take
advantage of all of these cores and take
computations that were sequential and
make them run faster and fork/join is a
popular paradigm that makes it fairly
easy it's a nice easy abstraction to
think about how you break things things
up break something into pieces maybe
even have nested fork/join that all
works and so there's a bunch of
different libraries that exploit exactly
this provide this sort of API so
MapReduce is of fork/join framework silk
is this programming language I described
earlier intel's thread building blocks
library I should add Java also has a new
fork/join library that's coming out
again to just enable programmers to use
this paradigm okay so so let's see so
what's going on how is it possible for
me to take a code that used to run
sequentially and as I'll tell you later
get any performance out so magic not
much of an answer there are two pieces
here two crucial pieces one is some
magic which is really you could think of
as hackery and the other is ordering so
we need ordering and we need this
hackery to make this work so first I'll
talk about the hackery so this is going
to sound terrifyingly evil or
awesomely clever you decide okay so
here's what we do first
so we take these threads you know you've
got this program and it spawns threads
we're gonna turn this program that was
written using threads into a program
that uses Forks that is UNIX level
process creation alright so you may be
thinking to yourself dear God why would
you do this but it will become clear in
a minute
and I should add right now this is
implemented in Linux Fork is actually
quite efficient in fact thread creation
is it uses the exact same code bases
fork so the difference in terms of
performance as you'll see is not really
a material problem what we do this for
actually is to provide isolation so the
great thing about processes is processes
have separate address spaces so what I
can do is I can run one thread and run
another thread and all of their local
effects are isolated from each other so
we're going to use this to enable
speculation and that's how we're going
to get performance so for example I can
start running f of X and I can then run
G of X completely in parallel and if one
of them does something that would
violate the sequential ordering I can
always throw away its results and
execute it again so in the worst case
I'll end up with the sequential
execution I will hopefully not be in
that case and I'll get some parallelism
out all right
so and it turns out nested threads are
okay I'm not gonna explain the details
here you may be asking yourself wait a
minute these are in separate address
spaces where you should be asking
yourself they're in separate address
spaces you know F does something G does
something but they're totally separate
processes right they can't see the
results of what they did it doesn't make
any sense so what we do is we actually
use low-level memory mapping primitive
to basically expose the shared space and
then each guy has a private copy of the
same M Map region so this is something
you can do with that map when you go and
you write to one of these pages
it's copy-on-write so everybody will end
up with their local versions of the heap
and they can always see say the heap and
the Global's that had been committed
before so it's a way of giving you
thread like convene
in terms of having shared memory but
still get isolation now when these
threads are running like I said they're
running in isolation to get all their
private versions eventually this memory
has to be shared right so all the
threads need to be able to see all the
results of preceding threads so what we
do is we impose ordering on how their
results are committed so there's no
ordering of the execution the execution
runs completely in parallel but f of X
precedes G of Y in program order
and this is the sequentiality we want to
observe so F of X's results need to
happen first logically then G of Y's so
what we do is we say well f of X is
first and it's going to get to commit
before G even if G finishes first f of X
then checks all of the preceding any
pages that it's read to make sure they
haven't been made stale if they haven't
it can commit and then to can do the
same thing when G of Y goes and writes
if it discovers that some of the pages
that it's read have now been invalidated
which it does with some version
numbering that's maintained down here as
well it has to roll back okay so in the
worst case you get back to cereal but
the goal here again is to make sure that
correctness comes first right we want
the program to behave correctly this is
think of it as an early unoptimized pre
generational garbage collector right we
want it to be correct will we got 35
years to spend making it run fast okay
well hopefully won't take that long okay
well if we can just get the TM people to
stop working on that then maybe things
will go faster so all right I'm sorry
okay
so so there are some other issues to
make this run faster so and I'm not
going to go into much detail about them
if you have a heap that is essentially
just one big heap and it's a centralized
data structure this completely will not
work because one allocation by one
thread and one allocation by another
will always conflict so the heaps
themselves the data structure itself
needs to be made decentralized in
addition you don't want memory
allocations that are sort of adjacent
like one thread calls malloc the other
thread calls malloc where everything
here is at a page
we're using em map right and we're going
to be tracking these things on a page
level if they're all intermingled then
you'll get a lot of false sharing so
what we do is we make sure that every
thread has its own set of pages that it
allocates from so if you have two
threads and they're allocating stuff
they're not going to conflict because
they're all on distinct ages we do
something very very simple with the the
gue new linker allows us to relocate
whole sections of where things end up in
the image and so the linker we basically
make the Global's page align so there's
a page before it and a page after it
this person prevents some false
conflicts that arise from code being
right next to Global's now you can be in
a situation where you have false sharing
because two Global's are next to each
other in memory and there's an update to
one an update to the other by another
thread we have ways of dealing with that
but I'm not gonna go into it
crucially we have to deal with i/o so I
mentioned that the the idea here is
basically optimistic concurrency but
optimistic concurrency means you're
gonna roll things back and as we know
it's hard to roll back certain
operations so Mars Hurley his favorite
example is launching the missile right
you've launched a missile Morris clearly
is a child of the Cold War so you have
this missile that you launch and you say
oops oops X was 2 that means Russia's
not attacking or whoever our enemy of
the year is so you
Renda it's too late darn right so so
what we do first there's a very
straightforward easy thing to do for
certain operations which is to buffer
right but there are some things that are
just out and out or revocable so for
example if you have a network connection
right so I want to initiate a connection
to some remote server and get a response
I can't buffer that right I need that
response right so I really really do
need to execute it so what do we do so
the trick here all we have to do is we
take advantage of the ordering so we
know for example if we're the if there
we have no predecessors that we are
going to commit our state so whenever we
get to an irrevocable point we say hey
are there any predecessor threads that
are supposed to commit before me no ok
is all my state
completely clean yes I can go because I
know I'm not going to roll back I'm
guaranteed to commit alright so that
allows us to actually handle all of this
sort of arbitrary IO difficulty even
though we're doing speculation okay yeah
that time do you guarantee that when I
see the exception is so if an exception
happens right now the exception and it's
not caught or I'm trying to understand
exactly the scenario that you're
concerned about so I mean this program
memory and I see segmentation for put
the same I mean if you were done the
sequential you would see it at a certain
point right but this would you end up
the same state okay so so let's let's be
careful to distinguish exception being
thrown from you know segmentation
violation right because one's a
programming language construct and the
other is the result of something
happening below the PL right so like
dereferencing naal or something right
okay so we could talk about the former
but the latter case what will happen is
the thread will detect it currently the
way grace works is it actually uses
segmentation violations as read and
write barrier so the very first time you
read a page and the very first time you
write a page you take segmentation
violations so you know which pages
you've read and written and after that
the pages are unprotected if you take a
subsequent segmentation violation then
grace will say wait a minute you
actually had a program error and it will
abort that thread which is actually a
process so weirdly it won't take down
the the program it'll just take down the
thread so it actually is arguably better
than sequential in this case in the
program then that the program will
actually survive so if you have a thread
imagine you spawn a thread and the
thread immediately dereferences null it
will be as if that thread had no effect
right because none of its changes will
ever get committed yeah it's an
interesting question yeah yeah yeah so
we thought about this we said do we want
to enforce the semantics we're when bad
things happen we just abort everything
or not and it's a flag it's some trivial
we basically either say you know
basically we have died and you send a
signal to your parents you basically
return in in you know in unix terms you
return negative 1 instead of 0 it
discovers that something bad has
happened and everybody fails or you just
fail silently and this is really a
policy decision I think that Kartik is
concerned about repeatability or
preserving the semantics of execution
and I think it's a it's an interesting
question
only well not only but especially to me
in this issue of if I've got code and it
has some sort of an error what do I want
to do about it
and in sequential case the normal thing
is you you crash right and if you have a
multi-threaded case the same thing
happens something bad happens and but it
happens in an undetermined time it would
be easy to tell like I said the current
runtime system actually behaves more
nicely but it's literally a matter of
saying return zero or return negative
one yeah
and negative effect of turning deadlock
in July
silently skipping that seems worse okay
so so it's not charting deadlock into
life right okay in a sense that you're
taking deadlock you know your machine's
frozen yeah absolutely so now you're
taking something where you would have
known it crash now you can gather
crashes right so you know you're willing
to let it be a policy decision or not
one since you seem to know sure it has
to do with performance no does not have
to do it no I mean actually you know I
thought that this was I think that this
is a philosophical argument I guess I
could put on my Martin Reinhart hat here
and say you know if you have a code and
the code is going to abort what do you
want to do do you want the code to abort
or do you want it to try to continue to
execute and it depends right this is one
of those classic situations where in
some cases you really want fail stop
behavior and in other cases you don't
I'm so cavalier ah yeah
you know I mean we can be we can be as
anal as we want and we can crash all the
time and that that's not a problem okay
it's not really something that I focused
on but Kartik asked this question is
that okay so some results the results
here are mostly to show you that that
this is promising there's some
surprising results they were certainly
surprising to me so let me explain this
graph this graph was meant to see what
the overhead was of using processes
instead of using threads so we're at a
very simple benchmark where the code
just you know it spawns a bunch of
threads the threads do some work it's an
eight running on an eight core machine
and so basically and it spawns eight
threads okay so the top line which is P
threads everything is normalized to P
threads so here this means that grace is
performing better than threads it's
running in less time okay
and as the the granularity increases
this is on a log scale right yeah yeah
bear with me this so as the granular
increases gradually grace eventually
sort of asymptotes out as you can make
sense right you've got the process and a
threat
you would think as I thought that well
there's the initial penalty of spawning
a process because you you know you shoot
down the TLB you have you know you have
to copy file handles you have stuff that
you have to do and then that's the
threat gets longer and longer it would
be amortized only that's not what
happens okay what happens is that for
short-lived threads you actually got
better performance and it came basically
this doesn't happen if you do you know
one thread at a time but it happens when
you do eight threads all right so my
student came and gave me this graph
which as you can imagine I expected this
bar to be up there and knocked down here
and I said all right I've done this to
the students several times now and I
really need to start learning I said you
did something wrong go find out what you
did wrong and fix it right like you got
the graph axes backwards or something
and he ran it again he got the exact
same results and I said all right let's
try this I'll run it myself
so ran the code and got the exact same
results and I said huh okay something is
very very wrong right it's like I'm on
candid camera something weird is
happening so so it turns out we did
everything we said all right let's look
at the performance counters let's see
what the hell's going on eventually my
student who is very very good in the
Linux kernel douve into the kernel to
see what the hell was happening and so
it turns out that it's actually the
Linux kernel that's doing it but I spoke
to a distinguished engineer at Sun and
Solaris does the same thing so I feel
like all right it's not just an artifact
of 14 year olds writing code okay and
the problem here this is the idea Linux
has this intelligent thing that it does
when you spawn threads if you spawn
threads and you don't say that there's a
specific CPU that they have affinity to
then it keeps it on the same CPU where
it was spawned for some period of time
the idea is you know the cache is all
warmed up it's a thread it shares the
same address space let's optimize for
that case and then as the thread runs
for longer we'll load balance it
all right with processes processes don't
share address space they should be
distributed immediately so in fact this
actually works in our favor
because the processes are immediately
load balanced they're spewed across all
available cords as fast as possible and
so that's why we get a speed-up so I'm
certainly not advertising this as some
technique to improve the speed of your
programs it was intended to just measure
what the overhead was of using these
processes and it turns out that there
really is effectively because of this
artifact not even no overhead it's
negative overhead which is not bad yes
absolutely absolutely so if you think so
I mean if you were to use silk right so
these threads I mean it would basically
be you know consider the situation out
here at the extreme edge right where the
thread has been running for a long time
here it's a second right all over the
startup overhead is gone everything has
been load balanced out you know this is
the standard sort of you know kernel
threads that are sitting here with their
own like decks right and so you know you
end up at the same place and here you
the axes are coincident so I think
that's where you'd be
okay so I mean at one millisecond I
think that it would be you know it might
be around I don't know I mean right here
the processes are faster because they're
load-balanced I would expect it to be
about the same right that the gap would
go away you know if they're already
running for all they've already been
running a long time then they're already
been load-balanced out right so they're
all spread out yep absolutely absolutely
you still have that's in you that's
right that's right and well I can talk
about this more when I get to some of
the other results gonna talk a little
bit about silk but you're absolutely
right I mean if you think of a framework
like silk or essentially it's follow-on
which is the Intel thread building
blocks the idea is you have some set of
kernel threads and then thread spawns
are really very very lightweight
continuations so there's no OS
involvement at all so they're quite
cheap and the goal there was to optimize
fine-grained thread behavior okay so um
that said all the issues of process
creation and stuff with the exception of
very very fine-grained stuff which I can
talk about in a minute are really not
the overheads of grace the overhead of
grace is about rollback and so we wrote
a little micro benchmark that just
simulates the effect of different
rollback rates and as the rollback rates
increase unsurprisingly performance
declines the ideal is eight that the
dotted line here is with P threads which
of course never rollback and then here
you get grace so as roll backs increase
you eventually start heading more and
more cereal the good news is that you
can withstand some number some
percentage of rollback rate and still
get reasonable speed up but you know all
of the steps that we take to eliminate
fall shearing are really crucial and if
you have true sharing of course it's not
a good situation
yes very
it is Apple storages in this sense here
it's the exact same program okay one of
them is using pthreads we're using locks
to modify some shared data yes yes and
so grace ignores the locks and just
treats the the thing is sort of a
transaction they are no no it's the
exact same absolutely yeah in both cases
these are the same programs just one is
linked with P threads once linked with
grace
okay so right so here's my disclaimer so
these are the benchmarks that we're
using it turns out that it's actually
quite hard to find benchmarks that
exclusively rely on fork/join a lot of
the classic also crappy benchmarks like
splash rely on barriers and barriers
while they are conceptually at a high
level like fork/join they actually break
up the threads so it doesn't make sense
for them to be you know if you think
about it you've got thread 1 and thread
2 and they have a barrier they join and
then you have the next threads if they
had been spawned two threads wait for
them spawn two threads wait for them
that would be a perfect fit for grace
but with a barrier breaking them up the
sequential composability thing doesn't
work right but so these are drawn from
two sources mostly they're from a suite
of benchmarks called Phoenix which are
meant they're their benchmarks that are
used to test MapReduce a shared memory
version of MapReduce matt mull here is
from silk i turned out that the mammal
was the only one of the soap benchmarks
that scaled at all with P threads
because the soap benchmarks are designed
to stress super super fine-grained
thread creation so we subsequently came
up with a clever hack that allows grace
to run very well even for those but I'm
not going to present those results so
the blue bars here are P threads the red
bars are grace these are speed ups on an
eight-core machine you can see that in
some cases you get super linear speed-up
sand these are cache effects the good
you know the good thing to see of course
this is a little bit surprising and the
reason this happens basically is that
lock overhead goes away with grace so if
they if the memory spaces don't conflict
and you have no rollback and you also
have turned the locks into no ops then
you get a performance
benefit which is nice not what we would
expect in practice so the speed ups are
good I have to note though we had to
make some minor modifications to these
programs the bulk of the modifications
that's the mods that we had to make to
most of them were this particular issue
which is you know as I described before
Gracie realises the way pthreads appear
in the code but if you do this spawn a
thread update a global variable then
spawn a thread and update a global
variable grace will say oh I have to do
the whole thread execution first and
then do the update of the global
variable then I can spawn more threads
so it's serializes all the thread spawns
so that was a real killer so all we did
is we hoisted that out of the loop so we
put these all in an array spawned
everything into an array they each had
separate result fields or something and
everything worked out fine so that was
the most important thing if we extended
the pthreads API with like you know
create multiple threads then that
problem would go away okay so here
k-means is kind of an interesting case
k-means has a benign race so k-means the
well-known clustering algorithm it has a
benign race where throws stuff it
basically is counting with which how
many things belong to a particular
cluster it converges so the race is not
really a problem and it's just a number
so it's an atomic value but for us this
is a killer because grace sees these
things and doesn't know how to
distinguish a benign from a malignant
race and sequential eise's everything
okay yeah yeah so that's right so one of
the things you know we just decided you
know for our purposes we said we're not
going to make pervasive modifications to
these codes clearly we could have
changed k-means to avoid this problem
right but I said well you know let's see
what we can do with local changes where
we barely understand what the program is
doing okay and and that was really the
goal so in fact one of my students was
like I think we can fix k-means by doing
X Y Z and I said no no no right that's
not the the object here the object here
is to come up with minimal changes and
in fact what we're doing now is we're
trying to come up with
ways of avoiding even making those
minimal changes right so the goal here
would be you don't change your code at
all and it still performs well right
okay all right
so that's the benign race all right
that's basically it so grace I think
again this is really about this sort of
idea of garbage collection for
concurrency in a way right I want to get
rid of all of these errors just like I
used to get rid of dangling pointer
errors with garbage collection and that
turns out to be a big win for a number
of reasons getting rid of sequential
errors it may be more costly than
running to the bare metal all the time
they're going to be different ways of
programming potentially but it seems
like a lot of Algol I'm you know it's a
these are promising initial results
right so if you use a cleverly tailored
algorithm to implement this kind of GC
for concurrency then you actually can
get pretty good performance you know I
should note you know this is sort of
transactions right but there's no
overhead on the mainline right so you
have these very coarse-grained
transactions there's no logging
there's no compiler involvement there's
no read barriers beyond the initial have
I read this page once and all of that
overhead is amortized so that's how you
get this performance and and there's
hopeful Wally yeah happy to take more
questions then well
benchmarks is that you're studying with
ventures that are already paralyzed so
this is a story about arguing I've
helped you multi-threaded code that make
everybody be able to use threads and so
on so so I don't have to start really
with its potential program and start
putting spawn and sinks into places
right that's right and now the question
will yeah I mean I think you know there
are deep problems right with writing
concurrent code beyond just the errors
right so getting it right is hard enough
but getting it to scale is a whole other
question so this is one of the reasons
why I personally remain skeptical of the
sort of vision of automatic
parallelization is that it's very very
difficult it boils down to algorithm
design right automatic algorithm
synthesis right so you know I'm going to
take you know you go ahead and you write
your sequential you know random sort
algorithm that works like this randomly
permute everything and see if it's
sorted okay I will discover that that's
inefficient and I'll turn that into
quick start to me that's it's tantamount
to you know this sort of uh you start
with the sequential program I'll
generate a parallel program that scales
and so I you know given that that seems
very very far off if it's even possible
at all I I figure start with the current
program but the concurrency here is you
spawn stuff but you're you're still
required there to the I mean the bad
part here is there's an additional
requirement which is not only do the
data structures largely have to be
distinct they actually have to be
distinct it's sort of page level green
which is a drawback of this particular
implementation but in the end you have
to break up data sharing I mean that
that's part of the whole the whole goal
though the especially bad part about
this though is that one shared conf one
conflict can cause an entire roll back
and that's actually something that we're
working on we have I'd be happy to talk
to you offline about this yeah
programs yes maybe not all well okay so
and you look at the the castle programs
in your sport drawing pad yes so you
have any data on home what frequency of
these it's a good question so I mean I
don't have you know data data I have
anecdotal evidence so the silk folks
have been working on this for a very
long time
right so silk is a fork/join model of
parallelism and they have written I
think three different race detectors and
in one of the papers where they talk
about it they call it the non
determinate er and the non determine of
the non determinate or papers they say
oh they they gave all these programs to
a bunch of a programming assignments to
a bunch of MIT undergrads and almost all
of them had race conditions so that's
that to me is suggestive that it's not
much easier
given the as a whole not too bad yeah so
yeah so the one change that we did in
matrix-matrix multiply which it is I
guess the most pervasive change was the
the base case for the matrix matrix
multiply was some arbitrarily chosen
number that turns out actually so it was
like I forget 16 by 16 or 32 by 32 and
we initially fingered that as being a
potential scalability problem because
you know it's very very fine but in fact
it turns out to have been tuned for a
particular cache configuration so we
made it bigger and making bigger
actually improve the pthreads based code
but it also helped us because it meant
that the blocks were it was basically 4k
by 4k or something the result was that
you were accessing things in page size
chunks at the base and the way that the
memory allocator works is the memory
allocator when you allocate a large
object it guarantees that it starts on a
page boundary so it makes the math very
easy so you know for sure
this starts at a page so I know that
this index range to this index range
always that's right I mean the real
problem with things like matrix matrix
multiply is that you're dealing with
with arrays and you have very limited
freedom to move they'll raise around
with other objects we actually have a
lot of leverage so one of the things we
can do so we have a prototype that does
this right now you run your program it
detects false sharing and then it says
here's where the fall sharing happened
so with Global's this basically means
you know oh add some padding with with
heap objects it means segregate things
from different call sites for example
yeah yeah we have although yeah I'm not
sure if you're on my schedule but but
yeah we I think you know this is
certainly there's nothing that precludes
this from being incorporated in a GC
language and GC gives you extra
advantages as you describe and there's
the ability to move objects around to
sort of shuffle them out or say you know
this is conflicting and then let's tease
those apart would make things
tremendously easier so we're in a worse
situation because we're in C and C++
than we would be if we could actually
move things yeah finer tree
where where the leaves of the tree
happen to sit at different pages and
then you put your marching on the tree
and your spawning threads with with
every internal node and as you're
getting to the bottom
you update to leave those do in that
situation are you going to do these are
n leaves notes are you going to do and
the work to end
that is do commit with every with every
level up the tree as well so each so so
let's see so if I spawn
I'm trying to think of exactly what
you're asking I mean the commits are
directly related to the number of
threads and when they spawn a thread so
when you spawn a thread that's a commit
point and when a thread ends that's a
commit point that's an interesting
question
so I I spoke to Christos about this it
turns out that using their MapReduce
implementation mostly impairs
performance and the number of lines of
code is not materially different it's
actually often larger for for MapReduce
it's not really a great story for
MapReduce on shared memory I mean the
idea of course is well this will make it
easier to write programs I mean I
corresponded with them he basically
thinks it's easier for software
engineering reasons and it makes it
easier to reason about the concurrency
but the performance story is not that
great so in fact I did include any of
the the Phoenix MapReduce based versions
for comparison because it seemed unfair
because they're all worse than the
pthreads version and pthreads to me or
the gold standard yes
how do you kind of extend this because
many will do right right so that's an
excellent question so and I mentioned I
was going to get back to this so now I
will so uh you know one of the things
that we encountered when we tried to do
this is I basically had a student change
all the silk benchmarks to use pthreads
okay it wasn't that hard it's mostly
mechanical you see you know every place
is the spawn turns into pthread create
and then you have to you know save the
results somewhere that's about it right
and the sinks become pthread joins okay
and then we ran them and none of them
scaled at all except for matrix matrix
multiply and when I say didn't scale I
don't mean with grace I mean they didn't
scale with P threads because they were
so coarse
okay so then I couldn't include them and
I was like damn
this sucks right this is a disaster well
it turns out we can run them now in the
way that we run them is through again
either you know devilishly clever you
know application of genius or a crappy
hack you know depends on the eye of the
beholder the insight basically is this
if you're doing nested you know this
nested fork/join sort of nested
divide-and-conquer which is the waste
soap works that means that you spawn a
thread you spawn another thread they
spawn threads they spawn threads they
spawn threads right so we reasoned you
know once you spawn enough threads and
the number of threads exceeds the number
of cores by enough just don't spawn
anymore just run the stuff so we use the
nesting depth and we say all right - to
the nesting depth once - to the nesting
depth is greater than twice the number
of course we don't spawn anything else
you just run the function and that means
now we can run we can run for small
versions even things like fib
we actually scale now and you can run
almost as fast as silk because at some
point there's no event
now this doesn't work if there's load
imbalance right if there's extreme load
imbalance so that one of the cores you
know has all the work and all the others
are idle you know in silk that gets
resolved because of work stealing for us
it would not get resolved there are
possible approaches that we've not
implemented one we could detect when
this is happening and roll back to the
spawn point and then really spawn things
or you could learn for subsequent
vacations not to do that yeah commit to
our speculator steal and if you are
doing this at a very fine granularity
then your page there were smart schemes
it working
okay so I'm not sure what you're asking
in that I mean it when you say
fine-grain I think fine-grain means
short-lived threads but are you saying
something else so if you write a program
that does this right
spawn eight threads wait for them spawn
eight threads wait for them spawn a
threats and those eight threads do
hardly anything then the approach I just
described will not work but if you do
recursive divide and conquer
where you say I'm going to carve this
big space into half and then half and
then half and then the leaves are a very
very fine grained computation what we do
is we turn that whole sort of forest
below a certain point while the tree
rooted right here into one big task and
so it works great disjoint contiguous
not required okay that's right yeah and
and that the conflicting potentially
conflicting pieces are disjoint right
yeah and if that doesn't happen then
it's a problem and you know that that's
a threat you know there's a tension
between how long you make these threads
last and what the likelihood of rollback
is so one of the things that we've done
that's not in this paper is we've
implemented checkpointing and the
checkpointing is even more crazy because
what we do is we basically here's the
very bad case that we didn't want to
have screw us do a whole bunch of work
update a global variable at the end okay
right and then oops we have a conflict
rollback waste the whole computation
right we do not want to do that so we
have a way around it and the way it
works is we periodically take a
checkpoint by calling fork again and we
leave that forked child as sort of
placeholder sitting there so we fork we
fork we fork we get to a certain point
and we discover a conflict we roll back
to the last fork and the fourth is
reawakened if we successfully commit we
just kill all those children so yeah
so so we're page easy successful I think
is that the first we had the mark or
said okay forget to leave it doesn't
know offering and we have a minute
memory yes that's your mom and now we
can work on all these cultural and
collection outreach right yeah now if
this were the end you could spend wants
to talk about it the to keep how to
implement it but at the beginning what's
them also your mall this well all these
things are no office on same things want
semantics is that the right Maul that
will enables are the same kind of
research that happen in GC to actually
succeed or okay so I'm by no means
convinced that this is the end at all
but what we were striving to come up
with was what does it mean for a
concurrent program that has bugs to be
correct so for a program that has
dangling pointer errors to make it
correct you turn off delete right and
you have this infinite memory
abstraction and so that's very clear
easy to understand easy to explain and
you know completely solves the problem
the question of what makes a concurrent
program correct seem to be a difficult
one all right what is the correct
version of a concurrent program and so
this is what we ended up with we said
let's find something where there's a an
isomorphism to sequential programming
and that's the correct program but
clearly this doesn't include all
possible forms of concurrency right
we've restricted ourselves to fork/join
and so it's a question whether we want
to extend this to include condition
variables and signaling for example but
you know what is a correct program now
that you basically have injected message
passing right I mean you know condition
variables are just messages and you know
the correct version of a message passing
program I'm not sure what that is
so but it's a great question
certainly one worth discussing over beer
all right thanks everybody